aujourd'hui quand on a une idée géniale
quand on veut monter une start up parce
qu'on sait que le produit qu'on a en
tête
en plus d'être révolutionnaire il est
écolo et il a tout ce qu'il faut comme
il faut c'est dur c'est compliqué de
monter une start up ça prend du temps ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie
ça coûte beaucoup d'argent et c'est un
peu décourageant souvent les bonnes
idées un raid dans les placards et si on
faisait tout le contraire imaginez j'ai
une super idée
l'un start-up révolutionnaire du 21e
siècle et au lieu de passer par ce
procès selon et fastidieux je vais vous
la partagez
je vais vous la donner je vais la donner
à tout le monde et tous ensemble on va
construire ce produit écolo génial que
tout le monde voudra s'arracher on ira
plus vite on sera plus fort et le
produit sera meilleur
bon ok je passe pour une espèce de
hippies 2.0 vous pensez que je déconne
mais en fait on l'a fait on l'a
expérimenté ça s'appelle pop 21 pop 21
c'est un accélérateur de projets pour la
transition écologique
ça a été conçu par wilshere un collectif
international dédié à l'économie
collaborative et open state un collectif
allemand qui expérimente des
laboratoires de mode de vie durable
c'est 100 personnes réunies autour de 12
projets répondant à cinq critères
le premier vous en douter qu'il soit bon
pour le climat ou en tout cas qu'il
favoriser la transition écologique
ensuite que ce soit pas un software
mais que ce soit de l'hardware un vrai
produit quelque chose qu'on puisse
toucher et que
le projet ne soit pas au stade de l'idée
mais qu'il soit au stade du prototype
fonctionnel ou en cours de
fonctionnalités et le tout sous la
bannière de l'open source c'est à dire
sans brevets sous licence libre et le
dernier critère qui est le plus
compliqué tous est disponible pendant
cinq semaines pour être accélérés dans
pau 21
parmi ces projets il ya le projet un peu
fou de jason jason il est finlandais et
il s'est souvent demandé pourquoi
personne ne l'avait inventé plus tôt il
a créé shower loupe shower loupe
c'est un système de filtration qui
nettoie l'eau de la douche en temps réel
pour la réintégrer dans votre pommeau de
douche pour créer une boucle infinie
génial ça représente 33 mille litres
d'eau économisés par an et par personne
soit 92 % d'économies pour me douche
il y avait aussi mauricio mauricio il
est péruvien il vit en espagne et il a
créé faire cap vers cape c'est un filtre
anti bactérien imprimable en 3d pour un
euro qui s'adapte à n'importe quelle
bouteille et qui permet de rendre nos
impropre en eau potable
aujourd'hui 4 milliard de personnes
souffrent de maladies liées au manque
d'accès à l'eau potable
je vais vous parler aussi de bissy
traktor c'est un projet que j'adore qui
est hyper rigolo c'est un tracteur à
pédales qui est spécialement destinée
aux petites et moyennes exploitations
qui veulent faire du bio ou de la
permaculture
ça représente environ huit mille
exploitations en france aujourd'hui les
douze projets viennent chercher du
soutien et de l'entr'aide pour être
accélérée auprès d'une communauté d'une
centaine de personnes mais ce ne sont
pas moins de 237 personnes qui sont
passées pendant cinq semaines à pau 21
alors qui sont ils des geeks des
ingénieurs des designers des architectes
des communicants des bidouilleurs bref
venus du monde entier pour faire
est ce que ces projets réussissent au
bout de cinq semaines et parmi les gens
qui vivaient là en permanence
il y avait les projets évidemment c'est
dit qu'ils devaient être disponibles
pendant cinq semaines
les volontaires qu'on a appelée no
angels qui étaient là pour faire en
sorte que la logistique fonctionne et
qui est du soutien tous les jours pour
tout ce petit monde les supporters qui
sont venus eux mettre la main à la pâte
directement dans les équipes projets
avec des compétences complémentaires
les mentors qui sont venus apporter de
l'inspiration et leur expertise
le temps d'une journée ou deux l'équipe
projet évidemment la team organisatrice
qui étaient là tout le temps et puis nos
partenaires privés publics financiers ou
non qui sont venus découvrir apprendre
et surtout aider les projets pendant les
cinq semaines
on a vécu tous ensemble pendant cinq
semaines mais où ça et bien dans un
château dans un super château du 16e
siècle à millemont dans les yvelines
donc une quarantaine de kilomètres de
paris et loger 100 personnes on peut
vous dire que c'est du travail
évidemment vous dites que c'est un peu
un conte de fées moderne là que je vous
présente mais je vais quand même vous
raconter les dessous de la vie de
châtelain
parce qu'en fait le château il était
disponible seulement pour 15 personnes
pour vivre donc nous étions 40 une
semaine top chrono avant le démarrage du
campement à venir et à construire de
toutes pièces ce qui allait être notre
maison pour cinq semaines
la première chose qu'on a fait déblayer
les écuries ont ni à installer un fab
lab géant un atelier de fabrication avec
tous les derniers équipements de pointe
et on ya construit nos établi nos
bureaux en open source pour le coworking
notable nos chaises nos douches nos
toilettes sèches
bref tout ce qui allait servir pour que
100 personnes puissent vivre manger
dormir travailler et co créé pendant
cinq semaines
p-au-p 21 s'est construit cette mini
société s'est construit autour des
valeurs de l'open source et de
l'environnement alors on appliquer
p-au-p 21
les critères de l'appel à projets on a
fait époque 21 pour pau 21
on a mis en place une politique zéro
déchet on a pris contact avec les
producteurs et les agriculteurs locaux
pour manger local pour manger de saison
on a créé notre propre compost pour se
doucher on a utilisé des produits écolos
sans produits industriels et on a mis
tout en place un système de tri de
recyclage et de réutilisation de nos
déchets et comme on est une communauté
ouverte et open source
à la fin de ces cinq semaines de travail
on a ouvert nos portes pour une grande
exposition publique
le temps d'un week end qui s'est passé
donc en septembre dernier il ya plus de
1500 personnes qui sont venues nous voir
ce week-end là c'était incroyable et il
est d'abord ils ont vu ce que c'était
pas 21 et surtout ils ont vu ces douze
projets les douze prototype finaux il
était tellement enthousiastes qu'ils ont
même passé commande qu'ils ont demandé
mais où est-ce qu'on peut se procurer
ces produits ou est-ce qu'on peut les
acheter
bises traktor par exemple ce tracteur à
pédales
ils ont déjà cinquante agriculteurs qui
sont intéressés pour se fournir chez eux
sauf que eux ils en ont rien à faire
devant le tracteur eu ce qu'ils veulent
c'est que les gens se l'approprient
ils sont en train de monter un cycle de
formation payante à l'autoconstruction
pour que les agriculteurs apprennent
avec leurs propres plans à monter ce
tracteur et surtout à savoir le réparer
en cas de problème shower loupe
jason il est en discussion en ce moment
avec un leader du bricolage qui
voudraient distribuer sa douche dans ses
magasins comme quoi on peut faire de
l'open source et gagner de l'argent
d'ailleurs si on appliquait la loi des
1% au projet pop 21 90 % des gens
trouvent les produits géniaux et or ont
juste envie de les acheter de se les
procurer
9 % vont avoir envie de les acheter en
kit pour pouvoir les montées même et
seulement 1% ira effectivement chercher
les fichiers sources pour
les regarder les améliorer et se les
approprier le bilan de cette aventure
c'est humainement incroyable et dingue
c'était vraiment très fort c'est un
projet entièrement pensée open source
pour qu'ils puissent être dupliqué
partout et par tous tous ensemble on a
bâti le poc le vrai proof of concept la
preuve de faisabilité d'un nouveau mode
de production pour une société post
carbone et zéro déchet et si on l'a fait
ça veut dire que c'est possible et en
plus on a prouvé que ça marche
alors du coup je me demande et vous vous
vous y mettez camp merci